Yeah, baby
Tom Cruise is nuts the way that he moves when he's doing those stunts is incredible
Did you know that there are only two people in the whole world who have to have their own insurance policy because
They're too expensive to insure. It's Jackie Chan and Tom Cruise. I propose we do three things
We do a running challenge. We do a jumping challenge and we do a
cornering challenge. The winner of this gets to wear the Tom Cruise jacket.
A museum would be built one day
of all of the Tom Cruise running sequences, where people in 20 years go like,
"Now, this is Tom Cruise from Mission Impossible 2," and they're like, "Oh," and then they go like to the next one
it's like
Yeah, it's a hallway of screens and in each hallway he runs by you
"Was that Tom Cruise? Follow me!" and then like you go to the next room.
I'm already wearing a medium size black t-shirt
So I'm already the most like Tom Cruise.
You think Tom Cruise reads those scripts before he shows up on set?
He is the script
He says it differently than it's written the script is wrong
The first challenge is the most essential one
That's so important to being Tom Cruise is the running challenge as you've probably seen in the movies, he runs
Incredibly well is his efficiency is at an all-time high for Humanity. His back is perfectly straight.
he's on the phone, cool and collectively,
he's relaying information
while there's chaos all around him
it doesn't matter he will get you the message he will get to where he's going he runs into people
he pushes them out of the way all while being calm,
cool and collected. Tom Cruise would have never stopped that take so you did good. Thank you
Oh, I'm not I'm not in the zone yet. Yeah, just you wait as soon as I cross the finish line, you're gonna, Tom?
And, action!
What is, is Ghost protocol your highest grossing film of all time
No, I haven't made it yet.
That was pretty good, that was pretty good. You got here so fast.
Look at that running
Dude all I heard was "my name is Tom Cruise". Yeah, that's pretty good. That's a very straight back, good slicing with the arm
Now he's kind of getting a little wobbly
Tom Cruise is just like direct. Yeah, I need to see more teeth. Tom Cruise has excellent teeth
Show us. You should show us
I'll show you
Tommy Thomas Cruz never runs in slow motion in slow motion Thomas Cruz Mapathu the fourth never runs in slow motion
3...2...1...Action!
What is your real name?
My real name is Thomas Cruise
Is Ghost Protocol your highest grossing film of all time?
I haven't made it yet
Smile all the way through showing the teeth straight back running, spin dodge around Clint. I think it worked well
There were some things you did right things you did wrong
You forgot to say codename Tom Cruise
So I don't even know if you're actually Tom Cruise or not. What did you not pan over and catch my brilliant move?
How is the construction worker hit? I was focused on the next question so...
Nah, it wasn't good
I mean, I didn't throw the papers. You didn't throw the papers!? You had one job. I know well
You had one job, son.
Throw the papers, son. I was expecting you to be way over here
Alright Wren, you or me buddy.
I'll go. Do you have a phone on you? What's a phone?
Action!
What is your real name?
Oh, my name is Thomas Cruise
Is Ghost Protocol your highest grossing film of all time?
Are you alright? No, I'm not alright. What happened?
Are you okay dude? Wait, finish it, finish it.
Is Ghost Protocol your highest grossing film of all time? No, I have not made it yet!
Are you okay? Honestly, I think if we sit down sit down sit down. it is yeah my gut region
I got hit so hard
My, my cruise pouch. Oh god here. Back's not super straight. Yeah, it's okay.
The chin is tilting down a little forward. Yeah, you ran cross-country. Got to keep the face up
Wren, did you, did you
Gut, elbow, gut
The phone dropped
I'm just, I'm glad you finished it, dude.
Congratulations on finishing, dude.
All of a sudden I was not holding my phone, my glasses were gone. All right, let's do it after all this to talk about Tom Cruise
I think it's time the real prospects rise to form in three two one go
Agent, what do your parents do?
Where'd you spend your childhood?
Yo, son, show me the footage show me the money. What do you guys think? I think the choice is clear
We are going to pick who's gonna be eliminated. 321 say it? Yeah 3 2 1
Wren.
Part of me kind of wanted to do the next challenge
which is a perfect segue to tell you about the next challenge and that is
jumping
How many arm rotations can you complete and how far can you jump
Jump and fly
Yeah, yeah. I got my left leg tucked when I landed. Had that going for me
Count 'em up. One two three
Three. That's pretty good distance
My strategy focused all on the arms
Go!
Dang I didn't get any arm rotations. Jake beat me.
So Jake got the distance, I got the distance, but I don't know if I have the rotos. Oh, yeah six inch
Oh, that's pretty good. That's three you got three arm rotations. It wasn't bad. That wasn't bad. That's three arm rotations
How do you count three? 2 1/2
Got one more left. Alright, let's see what Clint has.
I'm not gonna worry about the landing. I'm just gonna rotate until I crash like that's what's good
Action!
Who's who? Me, Clint, Jake. I didn't see the arms. I was just like Oh Lord, and I tell ya the arms were in dude
One two, oh the arm rotations good. Yeah, that's really solid
the arm rotation was solid. Clint, you're in, you're definitely in the next round.
I vote for Nico staying in. Wow. Wow. Wow, what? Wow, I'm honored, but you know what to be honest
I would have voted for Jake to stay in but that's cool. Wait
Are you just waiting for who you think you can beat in the final round?
Yeah, you're not everything you can that's why I didn't want to vote alone
The final round is cornering. He goes around the corner when he goes around that corner
He is at the most ridiculous angle you've ever seen.
It is so beautiful how straight his body is while being so far over. Two boys are gonna run around a corner
We're gonna put the red in a static position
We're gonna put a line of running that they cannot cross
We're gonna record the same frame of each of them running from the same static position
we're gonna take it into the studio and we're gonna examine it in post to see who has a straighter body and who is
Further down on the angle. Nico's putting on different shoes for the finale. Tom Cruise doesn't prepare for anything Tom Cruise acts
In the moment dude. He just is. I'd say just instant disqualification
You tuck that this shirt is staying in no one's untucking this shirt
Run
I can't tell who the winner is from this we're gonna have to go to video review. There can only be one Tom Cruise
at least in this office and
We're about to find out who we've got our footage pulled up
We've got the protractors on the footage to see the angle of the lean
That is pretty good that's that's why we I'm hitting max lean at the end. Yeah, I mean, oh it looks that way
That's pretty. Whoo. Okay, that's something good man. That's some good. That's all right. That's a that's a silhouette right there boy
You can see, you can tell i'm like,
Look at his head, look at his head
I will say that the spine is a little bit curved
It is it is Nico was definitely more straight in the future
I think what we could do is actually
get like
One of those levels for an iPhone start screen recording it and put it on a chest mount and then you run as your screen
Recording the level on your phone and I think we get to set this up like right here
So when we're running we can see like these so good and I feel like it's almost worth getting a hyper precise with this
This one embodies Tom Cruise more
You can't tell from that
Wow, let's see that again, let's see that again
It's a clear choice
I know my vote, I know my vote. Let's say it at the same time. One
Clint
Niko
You do your water breathing challenge yet?
Whoever can hold their breath the longest. I don't know if you want to take that challenge
Okay, I practiced I have practice reading good one winner. Only one winner
challenge
The winner emerges victorious with the jacket. Normally in underwater sequences people hold their breath for 10 seconds 15 seconds max
I'll count down slowly from 10
Ready,
You have to over train for sequencing 3 2 1 Go
Thirty seconds
45 seconds
One minute
90 seconds
Two minutes.
Two minutes 30 seconds
2:55
Three minutes
Just broke their own personal records
We're doing up to six and a half minute breath holds
With Nico as the winner by a hair
In the middle of it, I was just like I was like, wait a second. How do we know if they're still playing or if they've passed out?
An honorable match
Good game
This shirt is staying in, no one's untucking this shirt. Clint could stand up for me. Yeah
All right, you put your hands up
The guys over at rocketjump just released the second season of one of their weirdest shows I've ever seen it's really cool
It's called anime Crimes Division. Why should you check it out? Well, it's definitely one of their bigger projects
It's really funny. If you are into anime or that whole world like we are you should check it out
I think you'll get a huge kick out of it also
I had the pleasure of having a little bit of a cameo in there. That's right. I had to memorize lines
I'm just happy to help those guys out anytime they need it because it's really fun making videos with them.
Check it out, it's on Rocketjump. Thanks.